- I heard you have a birthday coming up.
- I do. I'm turning 40. What?
I'm excited about it.
- Taurus.
(audience cheering)
- Okay good. Yeah.
Yeah. (cheering and clapping)
- Yes. I'm a Taurus.
- (clapping) Yeah. How about that?
(audience clapping)
- You turn 40 this year?
- Yeah, 40 this year.
- I thought you were 29.
- You are so--
I don't care about age.
I'm not like one of those women.
I get excited.
I'm like a decade older than you.
So I'm almost 40.
And so it's a big
birthday year for me too.
I turn 40 soon too.
- Really?
- Yes.
- But you're a Taurus though.
(audience clapping)
We're both turning 40 this year.
- We are both turning 40.
- I'm excited.
- Congratulations.
- Congratulations, as well.
I love it.
I feel like life gets
exponentially better.
(upbeat music)
- [All] Hey Kelly.
- Hey Kelly.
- Kelly, Happy birthday.
- Kelly.
- Happy birthday.
- Happy Birthday. You're 40, oh my God.
April baby.
- Well, it's about time
and congratulations.
- Welcome to the,
you're now worth having a
conversation with, group.
- I hope that you have
an entire day and night,
in which no one disturbs the air.
- Happy Birthday, you dear Taurus, Kelly.
- Happy 30th birthday, it's great --
what? 40?
- How old is she turning?
Do you remember?
Doesn't matter.
- Female f-word, you're
so lucky. (laughing)
- 40, (laughing) it's nothing.
You're a little baby.
- You know, they say 40 is the new 20.
- Tell me how 40 is, so that
I can know when I get there.
I'm not there yet.
- Still have eight
years until my big 40th.
I'm just kidding, by the way.
I've got seven years.
- And it's crazy that you and I
are both celebrating our
40th birthday together.
Cause I'm 40 too. Kidding.
- That's the best. I'm 40.
I mean, I've been 40.
- I have already turned that myself.
I know it's hard to tell
cause I wear a lot of creams.
- I don't remember my 40th birthday.
- Let's get a facelift together.
We could do like a two for one deal.
- It's going to be amazing.
And I say that as someone
who celebrated my 40th
in the midst of a global pandemic,
alone over zoom.
So already, it's off to a better start.
- I know you're a Taurus,
which is fun and cool and great.
- I heard that you are doing
favors for other people
on your birthday.
If you could be at my
house around 5:00 AM,
that's typically when my kids wake up,
and if you wanted to take them for a day,
I would really appreciate that.
- I will carry your baby
if that's what you want.
But like, please don't want that.
I hope that's not what you want.
- You know if you work hard enough,
your career might get going.
- Just keep doing what you do.
Just radiate love.
I made that up myself,
that's my saying. (clapping)
- Oh my gosh, Kelly
- To the best coach in the world.
- We all love you, I love you.
- We all love you so
much, and you're great.
- It feels like yesterday,
that I saw you on my television screen,
and fell in love with you.
- I loved you when you were in your 20's,
I loved you in your 30's,
and I'm gonna love you
even more in your 40's.
- And I've spent 20 of
those years with you.
It's been such a ride, so fun.
- My Taurus sister. I love
your energy. Keep rocking.
- This is my official pitch,
for you to come make a
cameo on "Emily in Paris",
cause I really feel like
Mindy's singing icon,
as is mine, is you.
- You are just an incredibly,
huge inspiration to me,
always have been.
- And the most kind human
being ever, you're amazing.
- Doing such a great job,
And I just want you to keep going,
keep making people smile
every day and keep singing.
- Thank you very much.
You've changed my life for
the positive and I mean that.
- I hope you have an amazing year.
- Full of love, light,
health, and happiness.
- I hope you're having an amazing day,
whatever you're doing,
and very much enjoying yourself.
- I hope you have the best
one and you deserve it.
- You're a goddess and
I send you all my love.
- I hope you're having the
most amazing time right now.
Probably with Jessi Collins,
dancing on a dance floor.
- Celebrate yourself
because you're amazing.
- Enjoy your birthday like this.
(laughs)
- I was just gonna sing one of
your songs for your birthday.
- ♪ Since you've been 40 ♪
- I decided not to.
- I was gonna sing you happy birthday,
but you probably have like John Legend
♪ Happy birthday to you ♪
or some really amazing people singing.
So I'm just gonna wish you a
happy, happy 40th birthday.
- We wrote you the most
beautiful song for your birthday,
but what we'll do is we'll you the lyrics
so you can perform it.
- Yeah, you're way better
at that than we are.
- Yeah.
- I would sing, but I
don't do that, you sing.
- ♪ Happy birthday to you ♪
- All right, Kelly Clarkson.
(guitars strumming)
♪ Happy birthday to you ♪
- ♪ Happy birthday dear Kelly ♪
- Happy birthday.
- Happy 19th birthday, Kelly Clarkson.
- Happy birthday, Kelly.
- Happy 40th birthday, Kelly.
- Happy birthday.
- [Congregation] Happy Birthday, Kelly
(confetti pops)
(music fades out)